i'm sorry are you leaving i thought we  had a meeting no we do it's just i think  it's a little chilly in here are you  okay your eyes are glassy oh my god oh  my  she's sick are you sick no yeah she's  sick  that's why i'm wearing this and misting  myself with hand sanitizer i'm not sick  i just have allergies okay i took a  claritin and i threw that up so i took  another one i threw that up and then i  took a third and it stayed down i'm  getting better all right you're burning  up you're burning up what i have to get  out of here i have 2.8 body fat my  body's like a microchip a grain of sand  could destroy it  my body's a microchip  leslie go home no i can't i can't go  home i have to get ready for the chamber  of secrets